I don't really want anymore I'm running
through the godswood sniffing the dirt
tasting blood in my mouth but I've made
a fresh kill crowd when my floating here
in the yard
you wrote the fist of the first men you
were at hardhome you've seen the army of
the Dead you've seen the night king he's
coming for us
for all of us bran I'm sorry for all
that's happened to you I'm sorry it had
to happen here in our home it was so
beautiful that night it snow falling
just like now and you were so beautiful
in your white wedding dress I have to go
back inside bran I saw you at the
crossroads you solo I see quite a lot
there erin has visions my brother died
for you Hodor and summer died for you I
almost died for you Brian I'm not really
make your way home again only to find
such chaos in the world I can only
imagine Earth's is that letter
none of you knows the truth you held a
knife to his throat you said I did warn
you not to trust me what happened to you
beyond the wall I became the three-eyed
Raven uh-huh
I can see things that happened in the
past I can see things happening now all
over the world look at you you're a man
almost we don't have time for all this
the knight King has your dragon he's one
of them now the wall has fallen the dead
marched south
[Music]
what are you doing out here waiting for
an old friend it's time to tell John the
truth you're his brother
shouldn't you tell him I'm not his
brother
[Music]
the things we do for love and I would
still be Brandon Stark you're not know
I'm something else now what about
afterwards how do you know there is and
afterwards
I'm going to go now go where
you don't want it I don't really want
and you want who you wear the crown why
do you think I came all this way and
drogon he was last spotted flying east
rather away the better perhaps I can
find him to carry on with the rest as
you wish your grace